I have a fantastic decision to tell you
about that was made by a panel of judges
in North Carolina now it's just one
decision and it is a much broader
problem gerrymandering then one decision
can fix but this is the right decision
that was made and that's what matters in
this particular case the way that
Republicans drew the district lines in
North Carolina does not quote permit
voters to freely choose their
representative
according to Superior Court decisions
that have been filed and the districts
cannot remain drawn this way the maps
according to this ruling in North
Carolina were specifically drawn no
surprise we've known this for years to
maintain a Republican super majority in
the state legislature this is what North
Carolina Republicans are known for this
is what North Carolina Republicans have
been doing and succeeding with for a
very long time now there's an
interesting sort of legal circumstance
here that's important to understand you
might remember that just a few months
ago the Supreme Court ruled that you
cannot challenge partisan gerrymandering
in federal court and yet here we have a
Superior Court making this decision but
there is a rule in the North Carolina
Constitution called the free elections
clause which specifically says you
cannot do partisan gerrymandering
partisan gerrymandering according to the
North Carolina Constitution is
unconstitutional and that is what led to
this decision being made in North
Carolina
even though conceivably if it had been
appealed or attempted to be appealed up
to the Supreme Court the Supreme Court
would not have taken up given their
prior decision in June so the right
decision in North Carolina we know that
this has been going on what happens now
with the districts in North Carolina
there is a deadline until September 18
lawmakers will have to redraw new maps
which if they are fairly redrawn they
could give Democrats a chance to
actually do some damage in the North
Carolina state legislature in 2020 and
hopefully pick up some seats if
Democrats can pick up the majority
in the North Carolina State Legislature
in November of 2020 then they will be in
charge of drawing the maps after the
2020 census in 2021 which would be great
but again this is where Democrats and
Republicans were left and right are not
the same I have no interest in Democrats
taking over the majority in the North
Carolina State Legislature in November
of 2020 and then redrawing districts in
a completely unfair way that benefits
Democrats now you could say it would be
a just outcome because Republicans have
done it for nearly the entire period
between the 2010 and the 2020 census
Republicans in North Carolina deserve to
have the lines redrawn in a way that
favors Democrats instead of Republicans
we don't need to cheat to win
I just want fair maps fair maps are what
I want not differently unfair maps that
now benefit Democrats when it comes to a
lot of these issues I am NOT looking to
reverse the structural advantage that
Republicans have unfairly created for
themselves and created for the left
I just want fair maps because I know
that with fair maps and voter turnout
meaning everybody's allowed to vote who
wants to vote and their votes are
counted I know that that's enough for us
to win
however it's completely plausible that
the maps that are redrawn in North
Carolina between now and September 18th
18th will simply be slightly less
obviously unfair to Democrats but still
heavily slanted towards Republicans
that's a realistic possibility one of
the things about gerrymandering is that
there's a huge incentive to do it even
if it later is going to be tossed out
because people who were elected under
gerrymandered districts don't lose their
seats
if the districts are found to have been
gerrymandered and the map has to be
changed your election under a
gerrymandered map doesn't become null
and void if the district maps are later
determined to be unconstitutional which
is why they keep doing it you have a
census in 2010 the next year they draw
bonkers crazy districts they win seats
they maintain a supermajority then they
can actually push what they
in terms of bills becoming law for one
election for two elections whatever
meanwhile Democrats have to fight them
in court on the way the districts were
drawn and then if a few years later the
districts end up being tossed out you
picked up the seats the winners were
there they got to pass bills they got to
make laws and then you get to keep those
seats even if the judge says that the
districts ultimately have to be redrawn
this is the evil genius of partisan
gerrymandering even if you later lose
the other side has to spend a ton of
time and money fighting the drawing of
the districts and you get to keep all of
those seats that the gerrymandering
helped you win in the first place that's
why it's so pernicious this is why the
census matters so much and this is why
we need a there are models there are
endless akka Domitian's who have put
together models for how you should draw
districts computers can do it you don't
need people saying let's shift this
around and include this weird
protuberance in this district because
it's advantageous it's it's completely
unnecessary this is actually something
that can computers can do very well and
very fairly as Trump says it's amazing
what even kids like Barron Trump are
doing with computers these days we don't
need partisan gerrymandering we don't
even need partisan involvement in
drawing these districts anymore so the
right decision in North Carolina see
some extent too little too late because
Republicans in North Carolina have
gotten so much out of the way they've
drawn these districts over the last
several election cycles make sure you
are following the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show a lot of
funny stuff there and while you're on
Instagram make sure you follow me at
David Pakman we will take a quick break
and yes coming up next we will talk
about Donald Trump's Sharpie gait